now watch this this is this might be the
most incredible video of all of 2023
when you look at the totality of the
year if you had to describe it and it's
tough to do in one word what would that
word be and tell me why uh New York uh
this is a place where every day you wake
up uh you could experience everything
from a plane crashing into our Trade
Center to a a person who's celebrating a
new business that's open what bro what
are you talking about man first off I
knew New York is two words let's just
put that aside for a second I was in New
York City during 9/11 planes crashing
was not one of the greatest things about
the city it was probably I don't know it
might have literally been the worst day
of my life but like what kind of insane
statement is that sum up the year in one
word New York oh planes are crashing
into the Trade Center someone opened up
a pizza shop